what's up reject nations so
uh yesterday we of course covered uh
several marvel trailers from the
disney investor meeting announcement
thingy you know what i'm talking about
and they all look cool but there was
so much marvel news that did come out
that we didn't get to talk about so i
thought before we film our mandalorian
reaction for the next episode which
should be up
manana that means tomorrow in german by
the way i thought it'd be fun to just
give some quick
thoughts on a bunch of the news that was
talked about confirmed or revealed
in general starting off with i think the
the closer of it but
there's a reason that feige saved it for
last fantastic
four he called it marvel's first family
it's being directed by director john
watts from the spider-man movies
i first heard about it on social media
and i saw kind of a little bit of a back
and forth going on where some people
were really all for it and some people
weren't for it i feel like this is a
good choice
um not just because i'm a marvel shill i
mean that is priority number one
first and foremost i think they got to
play this one a little bit on the safer
side and if
john watts had only done spider-man
homecoming i might have been like i
don't know about this if you look at his
work in spider-man far from home
there's some exhilarating action in
there it is hilarious
between working not with just with
spider-man's powers but also showing off
the elementals mysterio's powers he
clearly knows how to capture
a wide variety of superpowers keep it
very family oriented have that heart
that comedic timing i just feel like
he's a good pick john quick thoughts
yeah absolutely i mean you know the
spider-man movies center around a
youthful cast and i feel like them
building this is marvel's first
family i feel like there is some of that
heart that needs to be kind of at the
forefront of a project like this
part of me is a little bit like i would
have maybe liked to have heard a name i
wasn't expecting or who hadn't worked
with marvel before but that's about the
only gripe i could possibly
levy at the moment i think it sounds
like a good idea
feeling confident confident okay and
then some quick
doctor strange multiverse of madness
news the character america
chavez will be in the movie rachel
mcadams confirmed to return
wanda maximoff confirmed to be in it and
he did confirm that these events do tie
in
to spider-man 3. and in regards to
spider-man news
that's about as far as it goes kevin
feige was just like
let the rest of the world take care of
it leading into this event
and you know dr strange will still be
kind of spooky yeah he's going to
confirm that too yeah he'll still be
spooky wait
thank you thank you for saving me there
absolutely got to keep the spookiness
alive
the dick confirmed black panther 2 will
come the dick of her black panther
black panther 2 will be coming out in
2022 i believe of july
they did confirm that t'challa will not
be
recast this is something that another
thing on social media that i saw people
going back and forth on some people are
really for it i think majority are for
that decision we were
opting for that choice as well that's
what we wanted there are some people who
don't like that they want the character
t'challa to continue to keep going
i mean we've talked extensively about
this specific topic but
it's cool to know that kevin feige did
confirm t'challa will not be recast they
will still explore the characters in the
previous one they will still explore
wakanda
john that sounds exactly like the most
respectful way to do it you know you
can't especially with how high profile
that movie is i think recast without it
being
just distracting and it's gonna cause
more people to zero in on and talk about
the circumstances rather than the movie
and i think that
to really pay it spiritual homage and to
take something
real i think will help you know make the
story better
probably is my guess i think yeah this
was the right move to make and
uh now i just want to see you know how
they carry the black panther mantle on
you know from t'challa very good john
thanks craig guardians of the galaxy
holiday special was announced along with
a series of animated
shorts i think for uh about uh groupt
baby group baby groot
all right that's what we need that
sounds cute it's disney plus all right
let him do it but the holiday special
i'm very much excited for
because guardians of the galaxy i
remember when it first came out everyone
was like this is the star wars of the
mcu
right here star wars is famous for its
holiday special they even just put out
that lego holiday special
which i really do want to check out this
is supposed to air before
guardians of the galaxy 3 obviously
around the christmas season before
guardians 3 comes out and they're
actually
filming this while they're filming
guardians of the galaxy 3 and it's also
written and directed by that gun himself
so i'm going to start a rumor right now
the guardians of the galaxy 3 is going
to take place
during christmas time in an au de shane
black
yes um but yeah it sounds like fun and
james gunn has been on social media
professing his unironic
love for the star wars holiday special
so it's
the group of characters to make one with
and uh i'm just
excited to see what they come up with
solid take john
captain marvel 2 there's another one
that is being confirmed
nia decosta directing who's coming off
of the very successful box office hit
candy man i think i love seeing that in
the field
it's great hopefully it confirmed that
monica rambo played by tiana paris who
you will see in one division if you saw
that latest trailer she's more prominent
in that trailer than the first one also
miss marvel will be appearing in this
one as well we didn't actually see the
miss marvel of sizzle that was released
but from my understanding of miss marvel
one of the things about her character is
like she loves superheroes and
specifically
captain marvel herself so to have that
kind of fangirl presence of her
and to have that really tie into captain
marvel 2 whatever the miss marvel show
ends up being
neat idea to get you to keep watching
that miss marvel show that's right
and to you know finally get fanboys and
girls to be able to see themselves on
screen
as the hero and all those rumors that
just dropped about brie larson being
kicked out of
captain marvel 2 or apparently not true
take that cosmic book dot news
kim fight did announce that uh secret
invasion
is gonna be brought to disney plus i
really thought that this was something
that they would
plan for the theaters how he was talking
about the fact that it's disney plus i
listened to the audio and i don't know
if i just
missed something or the audio that i had
didn't feature it i couldn't tell if it
was a movie or a show
yeah yeah i feel like it would be cool
to make it a series because it is one of
the biggest crossover events in
the marvel comics so if you did do a
series that was
based on that that'd be a pretty cool
way to explore it as opposed to just
leaving it for the culmination movies
and how many characters you could
possibly get in there
nick fury returning ben mendelsohn
[ __ ] i feel like part of what
they're doing lately is just looking at
all the things that have worked the best
lately and just finding ways of
spinning them off because that was such
a charming aspect of captain marvel and
so to have
this come to disney plus i would hope it
would be a show ultimately just because
it is such a
long game of a story you know and there
are so many characters that get swapped
out and whatnot so
either way it sounds exciting but
especially for the team up of those two
characters i would rather see that in a
long term format personally
very good john you said things i didn't
thanks greg i did i did my best
she hulk news tatiana maslany
looking at her name right now she's an
attractive emmy award-winning actress
whose work i am not familiar with in the
slightest but i'm sure she'll do a good
job but the exciting parts that were
confirmed mark ruffalo
will be returning uh not eli
tim roth will be returning as the
abomination
when eli roth makes an mcu i'm gonna
i'll eat my hat
also would she hulk this was a neat bit
of news that i thought kevin feige
hinted at the possibilities of what's to
come and i feel like chihuahua could be
a really huge show if they can if they
do
like include some major players here
jennifer deals with lawyer superhero
legal oriented cases
so with that being said that other
characters are likely to appear and he'd
and the way he said it made it sound
like we might get some big
players in here all of our favorites are
gonna get sued
yes we're gonna watch them fight it out
in court ant-man in the wasp three gets
an official title people
quantomania catherine newton is joining
the cast to play
cassie lang so we might see her fully
evolve into a superhero this time around
and it's confirmed that jonathan majors
will be playing king the conqueror
as was reported a few months ago this is
more
like confirmation news and also with a
title reveal and a lot of people thought
peyton reed might be the one
opting to direct fantastic four we
already knew all this news
thor four shooting in january nito
christian bales confirmed to play gore
the god
butcher as was leaked forever ago might
as well have just said it then briefly
about moon and i didn't reveal that
oscar isaac was actually officially cast
but he did touch on his complex
disassociative identity disorder and he
said all the characters are very
distinct that'll deal with egyptian
iconography but the thing that really
stood out to me the most
was the fact that characters are going
to be very distinct with these multiple
personalities
i'm wondering if it'll be done more in
the way if you guys have seen the dc
show doom patrol there's a character
there named jane has multiple
personalities like more than 60 without
going too much into the complexities
whenever jane is in the real world our
world
she does play all the characters when
she switches in and out of personalities
and it's a great chance for any actor to
showcase their talents
the idea of potentially oscar isaac
getting an opportunity
to sink his teeth into a role like this
could lead to like a tour de force
performance
or james mcavoy yeah
right i'm glad to have another
supernatural kind of story on the pile
too because like the whole egyptian like
you know he's imbued with spirits of the
ancient like
you know i i like the old timey flair of
that so i'm excited they talk about iron
heart by character named riri williams
who has the most advanced
armor since iron man oh
we'll see what happens there and then
there's jim rhodes
who's getting his own show uh
armor wars what would happen if tony
stark's technology fell into the wrong
hands roadie's gotta sort that out it's
all been building to it i'm wondering
if uh roxon might be involved in this in
some way but we'll see i mean the iron
man story was always building up to this
and it's about time that rhodey gets his
own stand alone don cheadle's earned it
by this point
uh like we've talked before about how we
feel like he's never really gotten the
chance to
truly truly shine oh he is the standout
performer and i really
like we know don cheadle can lead he's
led his own show he's led his own movies
and i feel like
this is a great opportunity for him also
uh yeah i mean when hearing the plot of
this i'm like well
tony stark being passed on maybe
there'll be a hologram cameo by iron man
in here
a hologram let's see and then yeah
there's confirmation on some other stuff
here and there but this was the news
this majority of the news
but the majority of the of it did stand
out guys which piece of news from the
marvel
slate and all this goodies is that most
exciting to you
is it still spider-man 3 toby maguire
and garfield all this being said and
it's still that
yeah kind of actually for me
still the most mystery there's still a
bunch of non-confirmations
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
video thanks for being here last but not
least
it's december and i gotta shout out the
man
who i view as the one who represents
santa claus the most i don't mean an
appearance alone
i mean also in terms of the kind of
gifts he tends to give
greggy that of course
mel gets tyler hague tyler
what can i say man i hope you have a
sweet ass merry christmas you're such a
jolly fellow you exude such positivity
everyone gets a nickname at our patreon
for the most part and you are our santa
claus
undoubtedly santa hay ho ho ho
to you and i hope this christmas
you gift yourself with some ho ho hoes
the candy bars not not the women that's
offensive
of creating the candy you're a wholesome
guy sweets because it's christmas
just stuff that matches your own
personality yeah
and some hookers